bonjour à tous et bienvenue sur public
sénat de retour de gironde où ils ont
effectué une visite de terrain les
sénateurs de la mission d'information
sur les conséquences de la tempête
xynthia auditionnent ce matin françois
baroin ministre du budget il faut dire
que les conséquences de cette tempête
qui a fait 53 morts fin février dans les
départements de charente maritime et de
vendée sont très importantes
il faut indemniser les agriculteurs
touchés par la tempête mais il faut
également indemniser les propriétaires
dont les maisons vont être détruites
mais déjà une polémique est née sur la
question du rachat des maisons qui ne
seront pas détruites
jean louis léonard député ump de
charente-maritime a dénoncé la semaine
dernière la gabegie d'argent public
estimant que l'état allait racheter des
maisons à prix exorbitants tout de suite
dont direction la salle clémenceau bonne
matinée à tous monsieur le ministre
bonjour nous sommes très heureux de vous
recevoir ce matin pour vous entendre sur
les conséquences de la tempête xynthia
on parle beaucoup beaucoup budget
finalement un bien sûr il ya eu des
morts et rien ne peut remplacer la perte
de vies humaines mais très vite aussi
les dégâts se sont révélés beaucoup plus
important que prévu un certain nombre de
modalités ont permis soit à travers le
régime assurantiel soit à travers des
dispositifs qui concerne les biens non
assurables de faire face à l'ensemble de
ces situations et donc je pense que on
est très heureux ce matin de vous
entendre pour nous donner des réponses
sur un certain nombre de points sur
lesquels nous nous vous interrogeons
peut-être que dans un premier temps vous
pourriez nous faire un propos liminaire
un peu plus générale et ensuite on
passera un jeu de questions réponses en
tout cas merci de vous être rendu
disponible ce matin on essaiera de tenir
les délais faire en sorte que à 10h30
vous puissiez vous libérer pour recevoir
une délégation du fmi je pense que si
c'est comment dirais-je l'avenir
budgétaire de la france qui se joue on
le comprendra le temps qu'on vous
libérera merci merci monsieur le
président je messieurs les sénateurs
permettez moi tout d'abord de rappeler à
cette occasion en effet que c'est un
drame humain
la tenue de cette région et je vais
évidemment une pensée pour toutes les
élus et pour toutes les familles qui ont
perdu des proches on se retrouve dans la
désolation et cette mission
d'information est un complément très
utile d'abord de transmission
d'information lé rôle et de la place de
l'état aux côtés des collectivités
locales qui ont été durement touchés
auprès des familles je le disais auprès
des acteurs économiques qui ont besoin
d'accompagnement et de et de soutien
devraient saluer le rapporteur et et
vous dire que c'est bien la moindre des
choses que des travaux côté le
gouvernement dans la disposition du
parlement sur ce sujet comme sur tous
les autres
alors ce qui a été fait vous le savez
mais je me permets de le rappeler de vos
missions que vous présidez
nous avons mis en place rapidement une
campagne de propositions d'acquisition
amiable les habitations qui étaient
situées dans les zones dites de
solidarité dans les deux départements de
charente maritime et de vendée
sans attendre une procédure
d'expropriation
l'état ne peut pas tout lorsque de tels
drames surviennent mais la pluie qui
l'appuient qu'il apporte aux victimes
peut les aider à se relever et à notre
conception d'un état qui est responsable
et solidaire à la fois j'aimerais
évidemment avant de répondre à vos
questions qui m'ont été communiquées en
tout cas les thèmes vous présenter la
méthode et le bilan de cette campagne
d'acquisitions a arrêté du 1er mars 2010
le ministère de l'intérieur a constaté
l'état de catastrophe naturelle à la
suite des dommages qui ont été causés
par ces intempéries
cette tempête du 27 février dernier dans
l'ensemble des communes sinistrées de
charente-maritime vendée deux-sèvres et
vienne dès la fin mars les services
locaux de france domaine où lancer
rapidement des évaluations des
habitations qui étaient situées dans les
zones de solidarité de charente maritime
et de vendée ses services ont fourni un
travail très important 7 jours sur 7
faisant même appel à des renforts
le but de cette démarche est de donner
aux personnes sinistrées les moyens pour
celle qui accepteront notre proposition
de chauray installer rapidement et dans
des conditions économiquement
satisfaisante c'est la raison pour
laquelle nous appliquons la méthode du
fonds de prévention des risques naturels
majeurs dit fonds barnier je vous le
confirme devant vous les maisons sont
évalués en utilisant des comparaisons
actuelle mais situées en dehors des
zones sinistrées
les propositions sont toujours formulées
à la suite d'une visite sur place depuis
la semaine dernière il a été décidé
précisé au propriétaire que l'offre
était valable pour ignorer trois mois
après sa transmission mes services ont
fait en sorte de pouvoir traiter les
actes d'acquisition de manière accélérée
dès l'accord du propriétaire sur la
proposition d'acquisition qui lui a été
faite par l'état nous devons pouvoir
conclure l'acte et le paiement du prix
d'acquisition sous un délai rapide de
l'ordre de moins de 3 mois je pense que
la qualité et la rapidité avec laquelle
l'état apporte une réponse est un
élément constitutif d'une un bon
exercice d'une mission de service public
dans une situation aussi dramatique
humainement
parce que cette question de l'acte de
propriété
dommage est un impact personnel
individus à londres jamais l'oublier
et c'est en même temps aussi un élément
du patrimoine qui pour certains auraient
pu s'effacer de manière définitive et
c'est notre rôle d'être à leurs côtés et
à vos côtés comme un élu local
lorsqu'elle est possible je crois qu'il
faut quand même aussi le rappeler grâce
à l'accord que nous avons passé avec le
conseil supérieur du notariat sur un
dispositif d'acquisition fondée sur la
rédaction et l'authentification des
actes par des notaires à partir date de
type simplifiée là aussi on a essayé de
mettre en place un dispositif de
clarification de simplification
dérogatoire mais bien compréhensible
dans ce cas là il ya un accord global
avec les acteurs du secteur
nous nous permet d'avancer à titre
d'exemple les notaires accepte de
réaliser des actes sur les biens malgré
l'absence des certificats beetle puisque
ces biens sont destinés à la destruction
par ailleurs à l'instar des actes passés
habituellement chez les notaires par les
particuliers et bien acquis par l'état
seront intégralement payée lors de la
signature des actes chez le notaire et
les propriétaires pourront ainsi
bénéficier le plus rapidement possible
du montant de leur acquisition
je voudrais maintenant si vous me le
permettez monsieur le président vous
présenter un premier bilan chiffré de
cette campagne
la date du 8 juin dernier en charente
maritime les visites sur place en vue
d'évaluer les biens à la demande des
particuliers sont quasiment achevés dans
ce département la formalisation de
l'ensemble des avis domaniaux sera
achevé à la fin du mois d'ores et déjà
160 de propositions ont été transmises
56 acceptation et aucun refus en vendée
il y à davantage de maisons et visite
sur place et les évaluations formalisé
devrait être achevée début juillet
excepté quelques rendez vous reporté à
la demande des propriétaires 252
propositions ont été transmises 71
réponse positive et un refus le taux
d'acceptation de la balle est donc de
30% à ce jour laissons le temps
évidemment aux autres personnes actives
les propositions ont été formulées de le
soin de réfléchir précisément à leur
choix les acquisitions des biens seront
payés par le fonds barnier là aussi je
vous le confirme officiellement sur
déduction des indemnités qui seront
versées par les sociétés des mutuelles
d'assurance au titre des catastrophes
naturelles
la trésorerie du fonds barnier et les
recettes annuelles du fonds permettent
de financer sans difficulté ses
premières actions
le fonds barnier pourra naturellement
être abondé en fonction de l'engagement
effectif des différentes actions du
fonds voilà quelques éléments chiffrés
technique et je suis naturellement votre
disposition pour répondre aux questions
que votre mission souhaite notre posée
merci monsieur le ministre
bon les fameuses zones de solidarité que
nous appelons nous zone d'acquisition à
l'amiable parce que ça permet de les
caractériser plus plus simplement
finalement ont été ces derniers mois au
centre de tous les débats donc il n'est
pas question de revenir avec vous ce
n'est pas le champ de votre périmètre
ministériel sur la cartographie sur les
périmètres en revanche puisque c'est un
droit que l'état accorde pour qu'un
certain nombre de sinistrés puissent
tourner la page le plus vite possible
les conditions de la réalisation de ces
acquisitions amiables la première des
conditions c'est d'abord la rapidité et
je crois que vous l'avez indiqué je
pense que c'est fondamental pour créer
une dynamique et pour faire en sorte que
les gens n'aient pas à attendre et de
une juste indemnisation
je dois dire que sur ces deux plans donc
moi je suis vendéen j'étais hier on
était en gironde avec la mission à
bordeaux pour l'estuaire qui connaît
aussi des problèmes importants et je
dois dire que aussi bien j'étais avec
mes collègues du chant praille team qui
s'excusait pas ils pouvaient pas venir
ce matin mais les choses ont vite donc
je crois que les services de france
domaine font font un bon travail et les
évaluations qui nous remontent sont des
évaluations qui paraissent très juste
très correct donc ça permet d'engager
une dynamique bons les chiffres que nous
av
indiqué son son sont importants
aujourd'hui vous nous dites que fin juin
toutes les évaluations pratiquement son
fait si j'ai bien compris et donc on
aura le fameux parce que le taux
d'acceptation de 30% vous nous indiquiez
c'est le taux d'acceptation non pas sur
ce qui envoie ça c'est pas de refus donc
le taux d'acceptation au fus dans un
décor voilà donc ces 99 % en pratique 20
je dire voilà le taux d'acceptation vous
que vous le calcul et sur le potentiel
en fait l'un c'est ce que j'ai c'est ce
que j'ai c'est ce que j'ai imaginé et
vous confirmer que la charente maritime
les évaluateurs ont fait l'ensemble du
travail je veux dire que les visites ont
été faites il ya sans doute des
évaluations à transmettre mais en
charente maritime
tout le travail était fait finalement
tout le monde sait ce que les services
de france domaine récurrentes et comme
information il soit allé en liaison
évidemment et 80 est ce que est ce que
vous avez en l'état les choses parce que
30% on a déjà un échantillon qui est
significatif
est-ce que vous pouvez nous indiquez
soit une fourchette s'il faut rester
plutôt sucré ou soit un chiffre qui
pourrait être la moyenne des évaluations
division soit acceptée ou fait je pas si
vous avez ce chiffre là et si c'est
possible de le dire ou alors une
fourchette
il est en réalité un jeu brillant il est
pas très pertinent
il n'est pas très pertinent et on
préfère parler d'une enveloppe globale
c'est un effort de l'état dans le cadre
du fonds barnier
l'enveloppé globale est estimée à 400
millions c'est ça le le fonds
mobilisables pour effectuer cette
acquisition mais une fourchette
il ya tellement des carmes d'être bien
placé pour le savoir que donc il faut
qu'on divise les 400 par habitant vous
laissez faire la moyenne car les
lyonnais une parole officiel du ministre
du budget responsable de france domaine
l'apathie alors oui parce que vous êtes
effectivement france domaine et placés
sous votre tutelle
alors quand on a entendu le patron de
france domaine ici il nous avait parlé
d'une évaluation de 800 millions d'euros
je l'avais fait répéter parce que
évidemment ça s'éloignait des chiffres
que monsieur borloo nous avait indiqué
la fourchette que lui ne l'avait indiqué
à l'époque mon l'a reçue très très vite
on l'a reçu dans les dents les jours
après l'institution de l'installation de
la mission il avait parlé d'une
fourchette 300 à 400 millions
donc là vous nous confirmez 400 millions
monsieur boire et auquel médiator
d'assurance lui nous avait parlé de 600
millions est ce que vous pensez pas que
400 millions c'est un peu qu est ce que
vous pensez pas que ce chiffre est un
chiffre sous-estimé dans la mesure où on
a la foi des maisons la tomate et maison
mais on a aussi des biens professionnels
qui en règle générale font l'objet d'une
évaluation qui est beaucoup beaucoup
plus forte que dès que des biens
personnels et particuliers des maisons
les biens personnels et
et les éléments professionnels 400
millions s'élève le estimé assez sincère
je crois de la réalité de ce qui est
nécessaire pour les acquisitions pour
les expropriations cet or bien
professionnel toute la filière agricole
qui a été pour partie très largement
sinistré autres pour le club d'une autre
analyse qui veut dire que en effet tous
confondus on aura une somme qui sera le
plus élevé avec moi je parlais des biens
professionnels n'ont pas effectivement
des dommages par exemple le mobilisation
du fisac pour les pour les petites
entreprises où la mobilisation du fonds
de garantie calamités agricoles pour les
agriculteurs je parlais par exemple des
artisans des commerçants et des
restaurateurs des hôteliers qui peuvent
se trouver dans dents au sein d'un
périmètre ont deux autres d'acquisition
amiable et qui eux suivent le même
cheminement fonds barnier
mais dans l'évaluation de leurs biens
professionnels srab se sont supérieurs
parce qu'il ya un fond qui se rajoute au
mur puis en général plus les murs vale
vale un peu plus cher vais vous quand
vous dites questions mineures vous avez
orthez puis voilà alors on reste un peu
sur son barnier puisque vous êtes mis du
budget
on a aussi auditionné chantal jouanno on
a auditionné le pôle medee m l'état est
en train de préparer le plan digues
on nous a dit le plan digues c'est
d'ailleurs juridiquement naturel mais en
servir du plan barre du plus du fond
barnier pour le plan dit bon très
franchement moi je pense que fonds
barnier
le flux annuel du fonds barnier
utilisable sait guère plus de 75 à 80
millions d'euros compte tenu des autres
engagements faille influent d'annuelles
si j'ose dire total de 255 millions
d'euros je crois que le fonds barnier
est alimentée reçues sur la surprime
catastrophe naturelle par une seule une
enveloppe l'enveloppent des 155 sur ses
155 faut déduire des choses qui
correspondent à des engagements
récurrents font dernier donc on ne peut
se servir restent disponibles mais à mon
sens à notre sens qu'une enveloppe de 70
4 disons 80 millions d'euros si on a une
évaluation de 4 à 500 millions d'euros
d'une part il faut quelques années pour
pouvoir faire face à l'indemnisation
donc de la carte pour le les zones
d'acquisition amiable et en plus on
pourra guère supporter le plan digues ou
alors il y aura des dotations
budgétaires tout à l'heure justement
vous avez parlé un moment donné pour
faire face aux engagements de l'état
d'une éventuelle dotation budgétaire
donc comment vous voyez l'économie un
peu globale dans les années à venir du
fonds barnier
peut-il faire face à la fois aux
engagements nécessaires pour payer les
particuliers et professionnels qui sont
dans les zones d'acquisition amiable
petit faire face en plus à une quote
part qu on lui demanderait pour payer un
plan digues nationale sur le broc prison
la république a pris des engagements en
la matière ils seront naturellement
respecter sur le plateau
ya un travail en cours vous savez bien
pour une évaluation précise et chiffrée
sur lequel est encore un peu tôt de se
prononcer concernant la somme général
pour les besoins en matière
d'investissement ci a besoin d'un
décaissement pour accompagner l'état
prendra évidemment sa responsabilité en
la matière sur le fonds barnier sur son
enveloppe sur son périmètre sur sa
situation
cette catastrophe est tant
extraordinaire dans tous les sens du
terme
c'est ce calcul de l'assurance entre la
part de risque la récurrence des
événements exceptionnels et donc le coût
sur le contrat qui est formulée à tel ou
tel acteur il est certain que un fonds
comme celui ci ne peut pas supporter
deux ou trois événements annuels sous
cette forme là c'est indiscutable
est-ce que vous avez monsieur le
ministre la répartition puisque dans le
fond barnier dans cette moyenne
admettons qu'ils aient une évaluation de
ce pas de deux cent mille il ya une
partie donc une partie qui va être payée
par les assurances les assurances payant
sur ce qui ce qu'elle aurait payé pour
remettre en état la maison donc et
ensuite le delta la différence est payé
par l'état par le mécanisme du pape par
l'état pendant oui ceux qui payent la
surtaxe des sciences va parle par le
fonds barnier
est-ce que actuellement quand vous quand
vous parlez 400 millions d'euros par
exemple vous incluez ce que non vous
vous c'est vous parler que du fond
barnier le régime assurances vient en
plus ça nous vivions plus et vous allez
il est déclenché par christophe rocca
corps et vous avez pas pour le moment
j'imagine de quotes-parts
assurance vis-à-vis des 400 mille neuf
français pas on sait pas si c'est de
l'ordre de 50 ou deux on avait dix mois
dans les premières auditions jeu plus
qu'il devait dis ça parce que c'est
bernard spitz où je sais plus peut-être
bien des faits faysal patron des faits
fait ça on a parlé de 20000 c'est le
gema oui donc c'est celle autres
boutiques c'est les mutualistes monsieur
j'aime à 20000 euros je crois au départ
par maison donc on ne sait pas vous
n'avez pas de chiffres actualisés pour
le moment non c'est pas encore puisque
les assurances ça rentre pas dans vos cc
merci merci beau c'est sa méthode je
sais l'étagé celui-ci dernier dernière
question sur le fond barnier c'est notre
visite sur le terrain hier en gironde
dans l'estuaire on a vraisemblablement
c'est il ya peu de maisons une dizaine
de maisons qui à mon avis relève du fond
barnier c'est à dire que répondent aux
critères savez à métaux la cinétique la
force d'arriver de l'eau non deux mètres
la distance par rapport à la dic mans et
la dtm et le préfet de région bernard
schmitt ont fait une étude dont il ya je
pense qu'il ya beaucoup plus qu ont été
inondées mais en fait qui répond
strictement aux hauts critères c'est
vraiment je pense une petite dizaine de
maisons est ce que on peut imaginer
est ce que le fonds barnier est
mobilisable uniquement pour la vendée la
charente-maritime pour xynthia ou est ce
que maintenant que grenelle 2 a prévu le
risque de submersion marine comme motif
ça ne l'était pas avant
est ce qu'on peut imaginer que
c'est c-17 petite dizaine de maisons
puissent faire l'objet d'acquisitions
d'acquisition amiable en tout cas
d'acquisition dans le cadre du fonds
barnier
il ya un amendement au grenelle 2 qui a
été qu'ils étaient introduits et qui est
revenu sur un point qui a inclus le
risque de submersion marine dans le
champ d'intervention du fonds donc le
c'est assez ouvert
en tout cas la position du ministère du
budget à ces ouvertures ce point je
pense que c'est sympa ce qui va
bouleverser
donc ça va pas sorcier film indigènes
des deux maisons à mon avis et c'est pas
la même évaluation non plus donc voilà
c'est on a suggéré d'aller au préfet de
saisir le meeddem justement pour que
l'on puisse actionné le mécanisme
bon je pense que sur le fond le fonds
barnier ce que vous n'y avait pas des
points que que j'aurais oublié où vous
auriez souhaité souligner je pense qu'on
a à peu près de ce conte par contre si
on peut avoir puisque on remet on a on a
un débat au sénat le 16 mercredi
prochain est-ce qu'il vous serait
possible pour au service là il ya une
actualisation je crois que c'est tout ce
7 juin
il ya sûrement un effet cumulatif là
d'ici le mois de juin est ce qu'on
pourra voir d'ici mercredi matin le
vraiment le point comme le point vous
avez fait qui est très intéressant le
point mercredi matin 16 sur le nombre de
commandes et va sûrement débat le soir
ici dans l'hémicycle on puisse donner ou
alors à chantal jouanno
bon voilà c'est qu'on puisse avoir les
informations qu'ils soient up to date
à l'époque du débat aucune difficulté
très bien merci alors bon bah vous gérer
nos financeurs publics et on vous
souhaite beaucoup de courage et vu
parlement
vous êtes vous aider dans cette mission
difficile ces réseaux pour laquelle donc
très vite on avait suggéré moi je vais
d'ailleurs à juin l'époque michel
barnier on étale à bruxelles on a vu le
commissaire européen car en charge la
solidarité régionale et qui en charge
notamment un fonds qui s'appelle le
fonds de solidarité est le fc sion de
l'union européenne qui avait été
d'ailleurs inventé et créé par michel
barnier au moment des grandes
inondations du denim voilà d'europe
centrale
j'en entends plus parler les contacts
qu'on a vu à qu'administration de la
commission et avec les commissaires nous
avait laissé un peu perplexe il y avait
en jeu quelques dizaines de millions
d'euros pour des travaux d'urgence et
pour des biens non assurables et ça
c'est important parce que ça pourrait
concerner des digues ça peut concerner
par exemple des routes communales en
tout cas souvent des biens qui sont des
biens de collectivités bon on avait on a
senti un certain nombre de résistances
de difficultés pour le pour le moment ça
fait quelques semaines qu'on n'a pas eu
de nouvelles informations est ce que sur
ce plan là vous en avez on a demandé ce
que je peux vous dire sur ce point on a
demandé le 7 mai dernier l'intervention
financière du fonds de solidarité de
l'union européenne à hauteur de 474
millions en vue de financer comme vous
l'avez dit ce qui était souhaité par
bonne partie des élus locaux à juste
titre d'ailleurs la remise en fonction
et la sécurisation des infrastructures
des équipements qui sont impactés par la
tempête
le nettoyage immédiat des régions et des
zones naturelles frappée par la tempête
elle-même et les opérations de secours
suite à cette saisine la commission doit
nous répondre
on va dire publiquement rapidement et si
évidemment l'intervention de ce fonds
est acceptée elle présente au conseil et
au parlement puisqu'il ya tous ces
procédures européennes que vous
connaissez bien succès notamment pour
l'avoir pratiqué les propositions
nécessaires à l'autorisation des crédits
et une fois ces crédits autorisées la
commission adopte une décision d'octroi
de subventions il ya quand même à preuve
le processus administratif relativement
enfin qui n'est pas l'horizon il
immédiatement opérationnel ce qui est
important c'est d'avoir l'autorisation
d'engagement donc nous maintenons et
nous exerçons des pressions vertueuse
auprès de la commission sur ce point
nous soutenons pleinement les demandes
des élus locaux des corps d'autant qu'on
peut en déduire que voilà il n'ya pas
deux a priori de rejet du dossier
compter dans le processus de décision
est-ce que vous pensez que le délai va
être est ce que la commission sera si
rapide que france domaine
alors vous avez les moyens de peser sur
france 2 mais nous avec moi un moyen de
passer sur la commission parce que vous
pensez que la commission pourrait être
réactivée est ce qu'il ya des délais
pour celle que ça j'ai dit non que dans
nos discussions sur toute une série de
sujets ça fait partie des priorités
essentielles que nous défendons que nous
portons donc maintenu une pression très
bien je vous remercie pour ce qui
concerne mon ado dit fier des aides mais
je pense que c'est les ministres
sectoriels qui pour mesure agriculture
etc
donc je vous pose parce que ce type de
questions on était justement las hurdes
sur les collectivités alors il ya un
souci spécifique sur les collectivités
puisque beaucoup de bien des
collectivités ne sont pas sont pas
assurables sur des petites communes en
dehors en dehors de la rochelle il ya
beaucoup de communes qui n'ont pas un
potentiel financier très important qui
ont subi des dommages très importants ce
qui me conduit à vous poser plusieurs
questions
première question est ce que l'état
mobilisera les deux dispositifs qui
existent un dispositif un peu classique
un dispositif de subvention
d'investissement j'avais posé à brice
hortefeux d'ailleurs là la même question
mais ça fait quelques semaines qu'on
l'avait recontré avait reçu il avait pas
une réponse définitive en tout cas il
l'écarté pas bien et pas de réponse
définitive donc sur ces points là est-ce
que vous avez des précisions à nous
apporter
et puis deuxième point les périmètres de
la fameuse cartographie vont avoir pour
conséquence de rayer de la carte une
base fiscale importante sont des
communes qui sont des communes
littorales sont pas des communes qui par
exemple ont une contribution économique
enfin le succès des substituts de la
table la taxe professionnelle importante
donc pour elles elles ont la taxe
d'habitation et le foncier bâti
c'est important sur des communes que je
connais mieux dans mon département mais
il y en a aussi en charente maritime
ça peut être de l'ordre du tiers du
potentiel fiscal
il ya des mécanismes qui existent quand
une entreprise par exemple fait faillite
dans une dans une commune il ya des
mécanismes de lissage et puis de
compensation fiscale escompte barça
c'est deuxième question donc première
question c'est pour les biens non
assurables
deuxième question c'est pour faire face
à cette destruction si j'ose dire
physique de maison mais en même temps
destruction pas seulement virtuelles de
base de base fiscale est ce qu'on
pourrait à l'instar de ce que l'on fait
quand il ya des difficultés économiques
importantes dans une commune pour une
part la taxe professionnelle il y avait
un mécanisme est ce qu'on peut inventer
le même mode de compensation parce que
sinon on comprend très vite vous êtes un
un élu local vous connaissez bien ces
choses là sinon qu'est ce qui va se
passer par les communes les
contribuables qu auront double peine ils
auront subi sinistre et en plus ils se
retrouveront dans une collectivité qui
courait les prêtres budgétaire et qui
devra augmenter les impôts si les choses
sont lisses et ça se passera mieux que 6
est survenu l'occurrence et brutale dans
peut-être premier première question la
mobilisation du du budget pour les
collectivités pour leurs biens non
assurables
alors effectivement c'est de coutume et
fassent des offres l'occasion de
l'expliquer les gens ne comprennent pas
parfois pourquoi commune ou même un état
n'a pas assuré son patrimoine
mais ce serait assez logique on a déjà
du mal à expliquer on avait eu ce
problème avec la tempête de 99
c'est normal parce que pour le coup si
petit tension d'entrée auprès des
assurances compte tenu de l'importance
du patrimoine pour chaque collectivité
tellement énorme que c'est la garantie
d'être obligés d'augmenter les impôts
pour couvrir une prime d'assurance qu'il
ne serait appelé qu'en cas de
catastrophe naturelle donc les colonnes
déjà ce travail de pédagogie c'est pas
de la mauvaise gestion ni pour l'état
nous pour les collectivités de ne pas
s'assurer c'est au contraire de la bonne
gestion c'est la part de risque qui fait
que le caractère aléatoire
non mais je le dis parce que je profite
de cet exposé pour accompagner le
message des élus locaux qui ont été dans
certains cas montré du doigt justement
sur ces points là c'est une tradition et
c'est normal et le france est un vieux
pays un important patrimoine c'est le
même problème pour l'état
donc ce qui a été fait ce qui est de
l'ouverture de crédits dans la loi de
finances rectificative pour les qualités
naturelles qui abondent et le fonds à
hauteur de
25 millions en plus c'est probablement
insuffisant mais c'est toujours ça pour
les éléments d'urgence et après on peut
regarder et je ne peux pas prendre
d'engagement définitif mais je suis très
ouvert à discuter avec les élus locaux
au ministère pour voir sous quelle forme
on peut co financé dans un contexte
d'ensemble sur lequel je n'en reviens
pas mais ça ne me rebute pas
intellectuellement d'imaginer que sur
des cas particuliers les missions de
service public sur un patrimoine très
altérée on puisse envisager de trouver
les moyens de co-financer pas
directement par le budget de l'état mais
par d'autres moyens enfin bon on peut
regarder ça sur le deuxième point ça
c'est un problème qui est plus large qui
est ça je n'ai pas le dos pas y avoir
énormément de cas dans l'histoire de
situations où une zone qui était
intégrée dans une base fiscale pour une
collectivité dans son final disparaît du
jour au lendemain
donc c'est quelque chose à inventer donc
à la question est ce que vous avez prévu
quelque chose aujourd'hui la réponse et
nous à la question est-ce que c'est
nécessaire d'y travailler ensemble la
réponse est oui on a encore un peu de
temps dans le cas de la loi de finances
pour imaginer un dispositif
je ne prends pas d'engagement je suis
très ouvert à imaginer quelque chose
d'original comprends parfaitement le
message sur la double peine pour les
habitants qui voient disparaître une
partie de la richesse et qui se retrouve
être obligée d'accompagner fiscalement à
la méditation de de leur commune
j'imagine que le moteur l'initiateur
sera l'intérieur donc sans doute la dgcl
est sûrement la dgcs qu'il y as entre
vos cabinets votre administration et
celle de l'intérieur la dgcl
actuellement des contacts sur ce sur ce
point là alors on a des contacts
d'autres
très fréquent évidemment avec
l'intérieur entre la dgcl et france
domaine entre la dgcl et là des défis et
on a sur tous ces points notamment sur
la partie fiscale c'est pour ça que la
dgsi de rentrer dans la danse à ce
moment là concernant ce cas très
original particulier il ya ce drame de
la disparition d'une assiette c'est pas
moi je n'ai pas même pour la grande
tempête de 99 il n'y a pas eu ça
non non non pas sur vos réalités comme
la cartographie aurait été qu'on centre
regroupe sur certains lieux dans
certaines communes et en plus c'est des
petites communes donc c'est des communes
fin celle que je connais bien c'est
souvent des communes de moins de 3000
voire moins de 2000 à deux moyens en
plus voilà donc du coup il ya une
destruction de base fiscale sèche
immédiate et même à une augmentation
spectaculaire des impôts rue de l'europe
à la fin ça vaudra d'être au péage ça
veut dire que on a déjà eu des
manifestations il ya des soucis pour ce
qu'est ce que sur les aspects donc
assurances c'est en auditionnant
christine christine lagarde
est-ce que je joue pour le moment vous
avez une photographie de ce que pourrait
coûter au budget de l'est tout compris
je mets même donc le fonds barnier
mais de ce que coûtera la tempête au
budget de l'état
enfin pas pour le moment non d'accord
non puisque les estimations sont en
décor comme je vous le dis sur les
autres points en cours d'évaluation donc
je ne veux pas m'avancer sur une zone
est ce qu est ce que vous avez un délai
un calendrier pour qu'on puisse le
prendre en compte nous donc on a entre
assure un pré-rapport de la terminer on
le présente aux commissions tout à
l'heure donc pour le débat la semaine
prochaine ensuite le rapport final début
janvier juillet pardon du réseau est ce
que pour début juillet il vous semble
possible d'avoir ces chiffres-là bompard
est trop tôt encore non rentrée l'un
fait notre bout voilà notre objectif
c'est de pouvoir être prêt sur une
évaluation sincère
et précise pour pour le débat autour de
la loi de finances pour abonder les
crédits nécessaires pour accompagner sur
le terrain d'accord et vous n'avez pas
du tout d'estimation pour pour le moment
on a des estimations mais elles sont
élastiques et si je vous donne ses
éléments d'informations contenues la
sensibilité de ce jeu il vaut mieux
qu'on soit en conclusion dans une somme
globale d'accord sûr on a souvent parlé
d et si au moment des auditions mais je
suis pas sûr va vous me dites issa cissé
de votre soeur ou pas sur l'origine de
catastrophes naturelles
c'est un dada mais nos collègues avaient
déjà pour la sécheresse en 2003 fait un
rapport qui prévoyait qui suggéraient
des pistes de réforme du régime de
catastrophes naturelles qui globalement
bon parce que il permet dit il permet
quand même d'articuler un régime
assurantiel qui responsabilise les uns
les autres mais mais en même temps avec
une dimension très forte de solidarité
puisque dès lors qu on paie une prime
d'assurance
on paie les 10% sur la catastrophe
naturelle donc leur accès
c'est important pour nous il s'agit pas
du tout de remettre en cause ses grands
principes là mais il nous semble que sur
un certain de points on se pose la
question d'une révision à ce que est ce
que là dessus
vous avez eu une doctrine ou non vous
savez les assureurs sont des
investisseurs institutionnels ils ont un
rôle majeur dans la protection du modèle
social en france comme dans le monde
entier et c'est toujours cette
différence de l'effort entre le
contribuable usagers et puis
celui qui finance ses propres contrats
l'accumulation des risques le modèle
environnemental mondial est un sujet de
préoccupation pour les états pour les
citoyens mais c'est aussi un sujet de
préoccupation pour ceux dont le métier
est de justement garantir les risques
donc il faut de toute façon ouvrir un
dialogue avec eux pour avoir précisément
la réalité de ce qui les ont à assumer
on a existé à regarder ce qui se passe
aux etats unis bp une responsabilité
incontestable indiscutable mais derrière
bp un système d'assurance et de
réassurance
il faut voir qui est derrière ce sont
des sommes absolument considérable dont
je crois que l'état seul même en appui
du parlement ne peut pas aller de
manière solitaire sur une telle démarche
de remise en cause d'un dispositif de
déclenchement de catastrophe naturelle
et j'ajoute que là où il faut peut-être
en tout cas réfléchir c'est que tout ne
peut pas être catastrophes naturelles
est ce que si ça s'additionne et vous
avez les cas de figure toutes les
semaines de communes qui pour un point
au point un autre voilà nice ya trois
semaines exactement et si on ouvre dans
ce cas là on s'éloigne du caractère
exceptionnel et dérogatoire du
dispositif de catastrophe naturelle et
comme toujours si on étend les la stip à
sanaa plus de pertinence n'a plus de
vertus après que feront les assurances
ce sera assez logique de leur côté comme
ils seront appelés à payer plus
rapidement
ils seront amenés à augmenter leurs
cotisations tout ce que l'on peut gagner
sur un point on risque de perdre sur
l'autre ont donc ce à quoi on réfléchit
c'est que il nous semble que notamment
avec le changement climatique
il ya une occurrence il ya des
mouvements qui sont climatiques qui sont
qui sont brutaux qui sont violents
et qui se répètent et la semaine
dernière on était en hollande qui sont
vraiment les leaders mondiaux de la
défense contre la mer c'est vraiment
extrêmement intéressant et j'espère que
le plan dit d'ailleurs va s'inspirer
très largement de l'exemple néerlandais
en deux siècles par exemple sur le sur
la submersion marine vous n'habitez pas
littoral quand même c'est important
qu'avec la république comme les
situations mais hollande
l'augmentation du niveau de la mer en
deux siècles et 40 cm à avant qu'on
parle de changement climatique les
experts qu'on a reçues qui sont des
experts le plus souvent de grands
organismes de recherche qui dépend de
l'état le shom cette mer ifremer
cemagref c'est un accès à tous nous ont
dit on s'attend à avoir dans siècle
prochain entre 50 cm et 1 m les
hollandais ont calculé les néerlandais
ont calculé que quand le niveau de la
mer augmente de 25 cm sur une durée x et
bien une catastrophe qui est de l'ordre
un aléa qui de l'ordre centrale qui
arrive dans un siècle il va arriver son
occurrence ce sera de l'ordre
je crois de 25 ans quart de siècle et
quand on est à 50 cm qui est la
fourchette basse de l'augmentation du
niveau de la mer qui fait consensus des
scientifiques
aujourd'hui on est tous les dix ans ce
qui nous amène à constater d'ailleurs on
le constate à la force de la répétition
de 99 klaus xynthia etc
c'est empirique mais c'est des modèles
la scientifique
ce qui nous amène à dire que on pourrait
demain
avec le fonds barnier avec la ccr la
caisse de réassurance avoir des
dispositifs vous le disais tout à
l'heure on peut pas supporter leur bon
c'est pas les gens de tempête qui va
nous arriver plusieurs fois de l'année
mais le l'occurrence risque d'être
beaucoup plus fréquentes répétitive est
ce que est ce qu'un ministre de budget
craint pas que tous ces mécanismes l'a
finalement à cause de ce changement
climatique bien ne vole en éclats parce
qu'il se révèle insuffisant parce qu'ils
ont été prévus à un moment donné bas ou
la fréquence de ces aléas climatiques et
aime bien moindres que celles qui
pourraient être à l'avenir
c'est une question un peu mais on l'a
évoqué avec avec plusieurs plusieurs
intervenants et notamment sur la
nécessaire je vous assure et ses serres
on imaginait que le fonds barnier vous
posé par une dotation tout à l'heure
quand on connaît et vous la connaissez
parfaitement la situation des finances
publiques
on s'était dit où l'état peut-il
chercher de l'argent et notre regard
s'est tourné vers la caisse de
réassurance bon j'ai pas s'il ya des
membres non ils sont pas ici bref c'est
que la caisse de réassurance rassure
donc elle est à l'heure c'est l'état
c'est 100% l'état c'est un mécanisme
aussi prudentiel acp maintenant on parle
de règles prudentielles avec solvabilité
ii ou ou bâle iii est-ce que c'est joie
parce que vous pensez quand vous parler
par exemple de dotation que c'est
peut-être quelque chose qui pourrait
être mise en oeuvre que là vous aborder
un sujet qui nécessite de notre point de
vue vous le comprendrez aisément une
digue budgétaire la réponse est non
la réponse est non parce que c'est le
doigt dans un engrenage qu on maîtrisera
plus en revanche sur les questions vous
soulevez on n'échappera pas et de
manière très rapide c'est d'ailleurs le
sens
le débat qu'a eu sur le grenelle 1 de
prise de conscience pour faire évoluer
les mentalités du grenelle 2 pour mettre
en place des dispositifs plus pratique
et adapté mais on n'échappera pas une
adaptation de nos sociétés
extraordinairement développer à une
évolution des conséquences
environnementales de l'activité
industrielle en gros tout ce qui touche
au plan d'occupation des sols ou plans
locaux d'urbanisme à l'utilisation des
matériaux à la réhabilitation ou à la
spécificité d'éléments de construction
sont les zones littorales avec marc et
sans marée hauteur de vue risques de
glissements de terrain etc
c'est une question pour la métropole
c'est une question pour l'outre-mer on a
déjà anticipé il ya quelques années sur
l'intégration d'une budgétaire très
forte qui doivent l'être encore plus
concernant les risques sismiques
donc c'est évidemment que ce sont des
postes budgétaires qui seront en
augmentation et que tous les toutes les
politiques publiques de l'état comme les
collectivités locales devront s'adapter
simplement c'est au long cours et on
risque d'être pris par le temps
démonstration est très spectaculaire
c'est convenir d'un ratio centenaire
rasulo décennale en très peu de temps
c'est ça donne le vertige
dernier point sur le on attend dans les
jours dans les semaines qui viennent le
plan digues
le président de république avait fait un
certain nombre d'annoncés aussi bien sur
le plan d'urgence dont jeu dont je vous
parlais
tout à l'heure ils pas les avais parlé
d'un taux de 50 % mais aussi sur la
prise en charge et avec un financement
de l'état important pour le plan digues
sur plusieurs années bien sûr il s'agit
pas de prévention assure seulement deux
ans trois ans ou même ou même cinq ans
donc sur une période longue
si ce plan digues va sortir j'imagine
alors bien sûr c'est le medef qui qui
est le concepteur comment il ya eu une
mission qui était désigné actuellement
qui travaillent mais une grande partie
du plan digues repose sur le budget
quand même sur les ressources que l'état
pourra consacrer à à la sécurité et
d'aider des gens et l'état c'est quand
même son job pinson son coeur de métier
c'est quand même aussi d'assurer la
sécurité des gens pas seulement avec des
policiers les gendarmes et en même temps
la sécurité maintenant tous les sens du
terme protection civile est-ce que vous
avez des contacts avec la mission
actuelle ce que je vous ai travaillé ce
que vous avez des pistes
j'imagine évidemment donc c'est pas
sorti j'attends pas non plus des
révélations fracassantes mais voilà ce
que vous êtes au moins associés et est
ce que le le le budget qui sera
mobilisée à la hauteur de ce que prétend
république nous annoncer on n'attendait
pas d'un moment du gouvernement qu'ils
disent que les engagements du président
la république ne seront pas tenues et
sur un sujet comme celui ci permettez
moi de vous dire que non seulement ils
seront tenus mais c'est une exigence
c'est un devoir président incarne la
nation il a pris ces engagements dans un
moment extrêmement douloureux pour tout
le monde
pour les habitants des départements
comme pour toute la collectivité donc
c'est un devoir nous sommes
naturellement associée aux travaux
d'examen du
du ministère de l'environnement on a un
travail et d'inspection qui les
accompagnent puis des cons à
l'évaluation
une fois qu'il aura un petit dialogue
entre les uns et les autres savoir si
c'est assez passé en tout cas
techniquement ce qui sera proposé sera
la lumière de ce qui a pu être pris
comme expérience positive dans les
autres pays donc on va le plus loin
possible dans l'expertisé on ira aussi
loin que possible sur la partie
budgétaire ça fait partie des éléments
pas négociable merci à leur propre mode
l'ajustement de ce qui pourrait être des
masses qui pourraient être mobilisés
chantal jouanno nous a donné un certain
nombre de chiffres qui sont qui sont
impressionnants sans s'engager à elle
même le dire mais et tous ces problèmes
en tout la différenciait seulement vous
parler d'expérience internationale
on revient de du pays bas alors on a
constaté que chez eux
vous allez comprendre parce que comme
une locale en réalité ils ont des
agences de l'eau qui intègre la
dimension eau potable assainissement et
en même temps protection évidemment 52 %
aux pays-bas qui les submersibles dans
les deux tiers du pib l'économie tant qu
évidemment c'est un enjeu national
extrêmement importants mais ils
parviennent depuis des années ils ont eu
leur événement fondateur c'est bon et si
elle est si elle est sûre mais où on
disait au xxème siècle c'est 1953 1853
aussi mornant à partir de là il faut un
plan delta et ce plan delta il à dos un
mode de financement pérenne moi ce que
je crains à l'époque
à l'époque on avait négocié j'étais en
pays de la loire au conseil régional on
avait négocié à quetta un contrat
etat-région bon et juste après la
tempête
et effectivement on a vu un taux de 50%
cinq ans après l'état revenait de 50 à
25%
je sais pas si c'est parce qu'on est
gaulois france est haute mais où que
l'on allumé on a on parvient pas à tenir
la durée dans la durée un effort soutenu
et moi il me semble que la meilleure
façon d'obtenir cet effort sans pour
autant menacer les finances publiques
c'est d'imaginer des mécanismes sur une
base très large parce que sinon c'est
insupportable évidemment qui permette de
pérenniser cet effort-là est ce que est
ce qu au moins vous dans vos services
travaillent à des mécanismes un jeu
difficile pour les agences de l'eau on a
un mécanisme peut un peu différent à ma
maman est ce que vous travaillez un
mécanisme qui aille au delà d'une simple
abonnement budgétaire annuel voté en loi
de finances
j'aime et qui qui permettrait vraiment
de consolider un mécanisme vraiment de
robustes
je crois qu'il ya un trait sur le sujet
dont on parle c'est à dire la question
des digues et son financement il ya de
temps il ya le temps de l'évaluation
précise
est ce qu'il ya de nouvelles zones pour
mettre en place des digues ou est-ce
qu'il n'y en a pas voilà c'est un
élément de stratégie il sans qu'il n'y
ait pas de zone
pas plus de zones submersibles
constructibles supplémentaires par
rapport à ce qui a déjà été fait ça veut
dire que quand même mené les aînés qui
avaient tous eu ça avait déjà
l'expérience du temps simplement ne
pouvait pas anticiper un tel phénomène
aussi spectaculaire et qui conjuguait
autant de d'autres phénomènes
extraordinaires c'est ça c'est la
concentration tous ces éléments qui a
fait certaines données a explosé ces
lignes alors ensuite la question du
financement et donc de la de la
méthodologie pérenne là il faut voir
avec tous les partenaires
c'est pas plus simple pour l'état naître
en logiques de subvention exceptionnelle
année après année c'est pas plus simple
et le contexte des finances publiques en
effet est un contexte qui nous amène à
faire des choix mais sur un sujet comme
celui ci il n'y a pas de choix à faire
il y à accompagner l'état à assumer ses
responsabilités en matière de solidarité
en matière d'accompagnement de
financement après qu'est ce qu'il ya de
plus astucieux qu'est ce qui est plus
durable qu'est ce qu'il ya de plus j'ai
un pertinents au fond je crois pas qu'il
ne doctrine unique ce qui compte c'est
ce qui marche ce qui marche c'est que
c'est dick soir fait qu'elle soit
protectrice et que le fonctionnement la
maintenance soit assumé et qui n'est pas
de risques là dessus alors oui ce serait
qu'on retarde le moment venu dans 10 ans
ou dans quinze ans le fait de revenir
sur ces ouvrages d'art qui nécessitent
d'être entretenue c'est là où à mon avis
il faut garantir le système pérenne mais
vraiment ça sera ça sera la conclusion
assez si si vraiment dans le plan dit on
peut concevoir un mécanisme budgétaire
encore une fois robuste pérenne qui
permet j'entends votre message de compte
qui permet si vous voulez de s'exonérer
deux mouvements de yo-yo de va-et-vient
de décision d'un gouvernement par
rapport à l'autre celle une espèce de
fonds de roulement c'est ce que vous en
dis moi j'ai trouvé ce que nous ont dit
les hollandais ils ont raison et on est
sur des événements sur une probabilité
est très faible
hum hum conçoivent des oeufs conçoit des
ouvrages qui peuvent résister pour des
pour une occurrence de dix mille ans on
est content dit milan donc occurrence
très faibles conséquences pour tout vous
dire qu'en écosse ce côté là c'est parce
que ça veut dire que nos maisons
ils ont barré leur delta avant c'est
autre chose et on ne peut pas transposer
ce que bon mais néanmoins il ya quand
même quelques idées à prendre dans la
modalité dans la méthodologie donc au
kef 1 1
occurrence faibles conséquences fortes
et mémoire courte
mais je pense que pour nous notre
mémoire est tout aussi courte et on sait
bien que dans dans dans une société où
l'émotion ou l'instant prévaut souvent
sur la longue durée
on parle souvent de court termisme ans
en économie mais le court termisme il
est consubstantiel je dire à nos vie
actuelle et ça réduit je veux dire la
vision et nos régions et surtout là ce
qui reste dans la rétine et et dans la
mémoire vraiment moi j'insiste si vous
pouvez avec vous avez les moyens
administratifs de le faire imaginer des
solutions qui soient pérennes je pense
que ce serait vraiment fondamental côté
jeu je pas à priver le fmi de votre
présence merci infiniment d'avoir et
pose une question non merci
vraiment on vous serez gré si vous
pouvez nous envoyer pour qu'on puisse
savoir à la date de mercredi prochain
les élèves en france domaine si on peut
aussi celui ci vous pouvez alors entre
les étages avoir une vision du fonds
barnier qui serait une approche une
extrapolation des chiffres que vous avez
sur
l'échantillon avec avec l'assurance
qu'on voit un petit peu ce que ce que ça
peut donner
au global sur la zone de banquise ition
amiable ça ne facilitera le travail je
crois que les collègues
or vous en serez aussi merci merci on
fait passer sa des possibles si bien
monsieur le président d'être d'être venu
pour qu'on puisse vous entendre vous
représentez aussi bien la greffe on a
auditionné donc chaque chaque niveau
institutionnel français on termine donc
par par les régions de france vous êtes
en plus concernés à plus d'un titre
d'ailleurs mais institutionnellement
comme président de région du conseil
régional des pays de la loire
donc ce qui nous importe aujourd'hui
c'est moi vous poser des questions mais
comment est-ce que l'une des deux
collectivités comme la comme la vôtre a
pu réagir à la tempête et comment est ce
que au delà battre la tempête et de
l'événement climatique a été un vrai
drame une catastrophe humaine une
catastrophe aussi bien sûr économique
matériels et autres
comment est-ce qu'on peut rebondir et
envisager le futur et est l'avenir pour
des territoires des populations qui ont
subi un traumatisme et dans ce que ce
que je vous propose peut-être c'est dans
un premier temps de vous laisser
peut-être faire un propos liminaire et
ensuite d'en venir
aux questions merci monsieur le
président donc je suis ici effectivement
comme président du conseil régional de
la région des pays de la loire est
également représentant les régions de
france avec deux fonctionnaires
territoriaux directeur général des
services qui a aussi la particularité
d'être un résident de la faute-sur-mer
présent dans la nuit de la tempête mais
dans la zone dans les zones sensibles
monsieur le président et ce cadeau qui a
suivi pour le compte de la région petit
fonctionnaire toutes les mesures de
solidarité qui ont été mises en place
j'y reviendrai
j'aurais dû aussi à voir avec moi maire
monsieur le maire de port des barques au
titre de des charente maritime et de la
région je crois qu'il a ici est donc mon
propos prendra aussi un peu en compte
les éléments qui leur est présentée en
direct de devant vous alors essayez
d'être relativement bref dans ce propos
introductif pour ce qu' on puisse
éventuellement répondre à vos
interrogations en complément des
différentes auditions que vous avez puis
eu rapport intermédiaire que j'ai pu
lire ce qui constitue déjà un point
d'étape suffisamment significatif pour
voir les orientations qui seront celles
que vous présenterez à l'issue de cette
commission denquête permettez moi de
commencer par une observation qui est
assez fondamentale crois mais qui nous
semble pas avoir été traités on prend en
compte la dimension de prévention tout à
fait légitimement dans des mesures en
amont des catastrophes éventuelles mais
y'a rien me semble-t-il jusqu'à
maintenant qui a été évoqué vous l'avez
sans doute évoqué dans différents
éléments sur qu'est ce qui se passe
lorsque l'on à une information et
c'était le cas à l'occasion de cette de
cet évènement qu'est ce qui se passe
lorsque l'on à une information en
l'occurrence alerte rouge puisque
là dessus je crois qu'on peut rendre
hommage aux prévisionnistes qui ne
s'était pas trompé qu'est-ce que quelles
sont les mesures qui permettent et vite
effectivement non pas d'éviter les
risques et les catastrophes mais
lorsqu'une catastrophe est prévisible et
hautement prévisible quelles sont les
dispositions que l'on est amené à
prendre je pense là aussi c'est un pur
presque un peu philosophique
métaphysique des rapports de l'homme et
de la nature
vouloir tout prévoir y compris en
fonction des risques maximum d'abord est
impossible on l'a vu avec le volcan on
le voit avec les tremblements de terre
par contre sur la manière dont d'abord
les informations permettant de connaître
les risques en urgence qui peuvent se
produire et quelles conséquences on en
tire à la fois en droit et en fait me
semble au moins est une démarche aussi
réaliste que celle d'imaginer les
hauteurs de digues la suppression des
constructions et c'est bien évidemment
qu est nécessaire mais je pense que cet
aspect des choses d'être retraité je
vous donne une anecdote que vécue en
tant que maire de la roche-sur-yon vous
connaissez cette ville également vous
savez qu'il ya en amont de la ville un
barrage une retenue d'eau une centaine
d'hectares 7 mètres de haut qui sert
notamment à provisionner la ville et une
partie du département de la vendée en
eau potable
une grande partie des constructions se
trouve en aval du barrage est en zone
inondable
d'une part si à quelques annulations
mais surtout en cas de rupture du
barrage et c'est une anecdote que je
vous livre puisque pendant un moment
lorsque j'étais maire de la
roche-sur-yon on se posait des questions
pour savoir si le barrage était bien
accroché et donc il ya eu des contrôles
laser je pense que c'est ça s'est
produit je crois aussi barrage de
mervent ou des éléments nature c'est des
mesures qui concernent pas seulement la
tempête donc il ya des mesures on a
mesuré pour savoir si effectivement le
barrage était bien accroché et puis il
ya eu des inondations même si elles sont
modestes à travers compte tenu du débit
de la rivière mais on ce qu'on a mis en
place le président c'est un dispositif
d' alerte phonique automatique
qui qui entassait spa qui lorsque on a
des prévisions de crues autres là-dessus
permettent d'avoir en stock en mémoire
tous les numéros de tous les habitants
du secteur actualisé et avec un système
automatique d'annonce d' alerte et c est
tout donc je donne cet exemple là qui
est effectivement un peu marginal par
rapport aux préoccupations qui sont les
vôtres mais je pense que dans la
dimension nécessaire de prévention il ya
bien évidemment toute la démarche en
amont mais il ya aussi qu'est ce qu'on
fait quand il ya des mesures d' alerte
comme cela et je vous en parle en
connaissance de cause puisque j'ai dit
que monsieur juin était aussi résidant à
la faute-sur-mer mon propre fils était
avec ses trois enfants
également la queue dans la commune de la
faute la nuit de cette affaire là et je
sais que quand on a vu alerte le rouge
quelles décisions individuelles les gens
prennent et je pense qu'on ne peut pas
laisser les individus seuls prendre
leurs décisions en la matière mais il ya
là un rôle des pouvoirs publics et des
mesures justement je me permets de
d'évoquer cette question là qui me
semble ne pas avoir été ne pas avoir été
me semble-t-il suffisamment traités et
là je crois qu'on a là des mesures qui
peuvent être prises à la fois en droit
et en fait est qu'ils n'ont pas un coût
et des mesures qui sont tout à fait à la
dimension
je me permets juste de l'aveyron pas
seul oui non mais vous avez parfaitement
raison
d'ailleurs nous penchons sur ce problème
là tous les maires qu'on a rencontrés et
en gironde hier puisque le rapporteur
qui s'excuse et il ne pouvait pas être
là l'envié n'y est sénateur de gironde
et qu'il ya une problématique d'estuaire
avec en plus une centrale nucléaire et
cetera et cetera c'est un des endroits
les plus dangereux de france sur les
problématiques qu'on étudie tous les
maires m'ont dit que il y avait un souci
entre le système de vigilance et
d'alerté et d'information
je leur ai demandé combien d' alerte ils
ont reçu l'année dernière entre 30 et 50
donc à un moment donné on crie au loup
quand on n'a pas vu le loup une fois
deux fois trois fois et cetera forcément
le le seuil de vigilance sa baisse
ensuite ils sont prévenus par sms mais
donc un contenu un peu nu mais afin
quelque chose d'un personnel et encore
une fois on est en langue la semaine
dernière les autorités nous disent qu'il
ya là-bas systématiquement un entretien
téléphonique avec l'élu pour qu' il ya
un décryptage une traduction d'un
message brut météo france ils ont les
previews avait bien faire le boulot
bref c'est qu'une surcote d'un mètre
pour un maire qu'est ce que ça donne
pour comme conséquence il ne l'imaginent
pas et je peux vous assurer que la
mission travaille là dessus que ce sera
on fera des propositions ça me paraît
fondamental absolument fondamental je
voulais évoquer cette question là parce
que ayant cette expérience modeste au
niveau de l'hypothétique rupture de
barrage ou d'inondation on a un
dispositif qui ne coûte pas très cher et
est opérationnel et d'un autre côté ça
permet aussi n'ont pas de relativiser
les risques et notamment le drame qui
s'est produit sur ce secteur-là
mais de considérer que quelles que
soient les mesures d'anticipation on
n'éliminera pas tout les risques et je
crois qu'il faut avoir un peu d'humilité
dans ce domaine là même si notre
responsabilité doit être pleine et
entière pour les éviter
alors à un aspect bien évidemment qui
est essentiel dans cette démarche là et
que vous avez longuement évoqué avec
d'autres d'autres d'autres acteurs
c'est tout ce qui concerne les documents
d'urbanisme les régions puisque
j'interviens en tant que région n'est
pas compétent dans ce domaine là et au
cours de la période récente je me suis
bien gardé de m'exprimer sur cet aspect
des choses même si bien évidemment je
reviendrai à travers les mesures en
perspective pour pouvoir éventuellement
montrer que la région les régions
puisque poitou charentes est bien
évidemment directement concernés comme
nous également sur cet aspect des choses
donc nous sommes intervenus sur sur
cette question là j'étais présent
lorsque le président de la république
est venu le
1er mars n'est ce pas en bandant les
régies dans les régions et puis dans le
calendrier politique qui n'était pas
très très facile
nous avons réuni en session
extraordinaire le conseil régional le 3
mars et le mercredi
la tempête ayant eu lieu dans la nuit du
samedi au dimanche
pour pouvoir prendre un certain nombre
de dispositions à la fois d'urgence qui
ont été adoptées à l'unanimité de notre
assemblée le poitou charentes a
également pris un certain nombre de
mesures d'urgence en la matière avec des
montants à peu près à l'identique autour
de 20 millions chacune 40 millions
d'euros immédiatement mobilisables dans
une logique de de solidarité sur les
compétences qui étaient les nôtres et
qui sont encore les nôtres pour le
moment monsieur le président monsieur
sénateurs notamment sur les compétences
qui sont celles d'aménagement du
territoire au delà de la solidarité de
relation avec avec les communes mais
aussi avec les acteurs économiques
compétences actuelles des régions mais
aussi sur les mesures environnementales
j'y reviendrai donc quelles sont les
mesures que nous avons prises
essentiellement solidarité à direction
des habitants et des communes solidarité
directs à l'égard des acteurs
économiques diverses et variées aussi
bien ostréiculteurs agriculteurs
touristique exploitants d'activités
commerciales diverses et bien évidemment
des possibilités direct d'aider les
communes pour colmater les digues vous
vous avez vu cette réalité là sur le
terrain nous sommes allés également
comme beaucoup d'autres sur sur le
terrain je signale qu'on parle de la
vendée mais qui a pas que la vendée qui
étaient touchés bien évidemment
charente-maritime avec torture
déchantent mais aussi la loire
atlantique qui a été pas tout - touché
un terme de vies humaines sauf
moutiers-en-retz avec ces touristes
laqué qui sont morts la nuit qui était
bien de femmes dans leur dans leurs
camions caravanes dans camping car et
mais les conséquences ont été également
réel sur sur la loire atlantique
notamment sur les digues d'une anecdote
que vous connaissez sans doute le maire
le secteur de bois un pouvoir qui est
responsable président de 21 km de digues
avec un budget annuel de 70000 euros
j'y suis allé quelques jours après non
mais je suis allé après il avait
convoqué et les pelleteuses 100 marchés
publics sera et sans le sou pour pouvoir
les financer y avait au moins une
dizaine de pelleteuse puisqu'on
attendait une nouvelle et il a bien fait
et donc nous notre notre démarche a été
d'apporter une couverture compris
financières au delà de l'aspect
juridique avec avec réactivité pour me
dire on a voté dix millions d'euros pour
éventuellement subvenir à cette démarche
d'urgence en la matière donc solidarité
à l'égard des personnes et des communes
solidarité à l'égard des entreprises et
avance pour pour les digues
une difficulté qui est toujours un réel
espoir c'est qu'au delà de cette
réactivité qui at-elle dît fonds
disponibles sait les conditions dans
lesquelles notamment les acteurs je
pense aux acteurs économiques en
particulier ont été à même de mobiliser
ou plus exactement de pas mobiliser les
fonds qui étaient à leur disposition
pour quoi et c'est un autre aspect de la
situation actuelle que vous connaissez
c'est comment
cain voulait pas parler du fisac
particulièrement non tout ou acteurs
économiques oui tout les acteurs
économiques
pourquoi parceque ils attendent un
certain nombre de décisions monsieur le
président alors décision bien évidemment
des assurances décision de l'état
j'aurai l'occasion d'y revenir
mais décision essentiellement des
assurances et nous les mesures en
direction des acteurs économiques
étaient conçus essentiellement comme des
avances remboursables les avances
remboursables qui permettait d'être
mobilisé tout de suite pour faire face à
la situation mais qui rentrait dans un
plan de financement qu'on connaissait
pas et que me connaissent pas est donc
très concrètement les ostréiculteurs
nous dit attendez moi je connais pas
comment les assurances vont nous
rembourser et donc moi je veux avoir un
plan d'affaires pour les années qui
viennent qui ne mettent pas en péril
équilibres économiques de main de ma
société donc vos avances remboursables
c'est bien gentil mais ça réglera pas
les équilibres économiques de nos
entreprises
même chose sur un agriculteur qui a été
victime là je suis allé dans son sa
ferme ya pas très longtemps qui a perdu
ses six cents brebis et puis c'est 70
vaud qui dit mais j'attends moi de
savoir d'assurance lettre de
l'agriculture etc
pour connaître mon plan d'affaires pour
que très bien les avances remboursables
alors ça peut aussi être des subventions
dans les mythes de droit mais je le dis
il ya donc actuellement et vous savez
une inertie très très forte
quant aux conditions au delà des bonnes
volontés aux conditions dans lesquelles
les mesures prises peuvent être mises en
ligne mais je absolument nous l'avons
constaté
on avait la chance la semaine dernière
ou la tiennent deux jours d'avoir le miz
l'agriculture avec la lmh à la loi de
médiation agricole ici nous l'avons
assez précisément interpellé il est
d'ailleurs venu à l'issue chante
maritime et en vendée pour annoncer
quelques nouvelles
mais voilà la situation est grave sur le
terrain les gens ont eu un premier
traumatisme avec l'atr la tempête ils
ont un autre traumatisme notamment les
agriculteurs quand ils voient leurs
vergers quand ils voient leurs céréales
qui qu'ils peuvent pas pousser
et en face de ça il n'y a pas un euro
effectivement qui a été versée là on
nous annonce cette semaine
un premier forfait mais je partage ce
constat alors donc à par rapport aux
démarches que l'on peut dire au constat
puisque l'anfac d'aig et des constats en
la matière c'est que on peut dire que la
mobilisation territoriales y compris de
l'état en région a été en région et au
département j'entends à l'état
territorial a été au delà des mesures de
solidarité tous les acteurs je crois a
été saluée de tous le monde dans des
conditions difficiles
mais était-ce à lui tout autant y
compris vous venez de l'indiquer les
relations entre les acteurs du
territoire qu'il s'agisse des communes
départements des régions où ou des
préfectures des services de l'état et
puis ce qui se passe au niveau national
et un peu de un peu de décalage n'est ce
pas et un coefficient d'amortissement
qui est très très fort est compris entre
entre les discours et la réalité de la
réalité du rhin ça me permettra de
quitter gression à la fin compte tenu du
débat actuel sur les rapports entre les
différentes institutions et la réforme
territoriale notamment
alors je voudrais évoquer évoqué
également maintenant plus exactement des
quelques perspectives
je sais pas dans quel temps je suis ces
quelques quelques perspectives que l'on
a essayé de mettre en oeuvre avec des
rencontres récentes avec notamment les
maires et les acteurs économiques pour
essayer au delà de démesure c'est le
sens des mesures que vous allez proposer
mais aussi également devoir de redonner
des perspectives à ce territoire ce que
je crois qu'au delà des drames il faut
aussi avoir une sortie de cette démarche
là qui est pas bien évidemment facile
quand même rappeler avant d'aborder
cette question l'âme le débat sur la
défense contre la mer
on a siégé ensemble dans la même
institution et dans le cadre des
contrats de plan précédent
il y avait une ligne budgétaire défense
contre la mer et croit que le sénateur
oudin a été auditionné il était porteur
et
rues de moutier souvent de cette
question là qui faisait l'unanimité dans
nos assemblées
je signale que nous avions demandé en
2007 à l'occasion de la négociation du
contrat de projet qu'il y ait à la
demande des acteurs à nouveau une ligne
budgétaire inscrite dans le contrat de
projets de défense contre la mer
cette démarche a été refusée par l'état
puisque le préfet de région de l'époque
n'a pas eu mandat pour intégrer cette
démarche de défense contre la mer dans
le cadre du contrat de projet c'est une
convention
c'est une convention particulière qui à
notre demande et avec la demande des
départements puisque les départements
ont été conçus la vendée et la loire
atlantique concerné par cette démarche
là à inscrire pour trois ans c'est
terminé maintenant une ligne budgétaire
réduite par rapport à ce qui se passait
précédemment et avec une intervention de
l'état réduit également
je n'ai pas fait de commentaire sur cet
aspect des choses pendant la période
qu'il s'agissait pas de me semble-t-il
de créer des conditions de polémiques ou
de chercher de pseudo responsabilité
dans ces questions là ça ne servait à
rien mais je rappelle quand même ce fait
qui est tout à fait tout à fait réelle
et ça veut donc dire que cette démarche
là que vous connaissez bien doit être
rappelée d'espoir puisque on peut pas
jouer au ping pong sur les
responsabilités telles que les uns et
les autres doivent les partager j'ai
rappelé à françois baroin tout à l'heure
pour l'avenant contrat état région et je
vous fais une confidence c'est que je
pourrais trouver facilement la date je
crois que c'est le 24 ou le 25
j'avais obtenu jeu depuis la fin d'année
la convention triennale
qui mobilisait de l'argent de l'état
donc les têtes est revenu de 50%
d'intervention de soutou a pas 25 pouces
de 50 à 25
et on était sans jeudi rendent était
sans nouvelles donc je m'étais adressé
d'abord aux mélèzes n'ayant pas de
réponse je mettais reporter sur matignon
et je n'ai eu qu'un accord oral je crois
que c'est le 25 pour la reconduction
d'une convention
à l'époque c'était un montant de 4 5
millions d'euros c'était quelques jours
avant le 28 février
tant que ça se passe de commentaire
donc nous nous avons rencontré les
maires pour examiner les conditions dans
lesquelles encore une fois sans nier les
difficultés actuelles que j'ai survolé à
l'instant qui bien évidemment sont très
très prégnante pour l'ensemble des
acteurs mais également comment comment
sortir si je puis dire de cette
situation et redonner des perspectives à
l'ensemble à vent à l'ensemble des
acteurs vous dire aussi et je reviendrai
sur sur les digues sur les digues tout à
l'heure enfin deux en fin de propos
alors nous avons proposé très très
concrètement on a délibéré là dessus les
acteurs le sable comment apporter une
assistance
nous cherchons pas exercé une tutelle
sur les autres niveaux de collectivités
territoriales mais comment apporter une
assistante indispensable sur l'ensemble
des préoccupations qui peuvent être les
leurs et qui sont les leurs actuellement
nous avons lancé une consultation avec
leur accord et les conclusions de cette
de cette consultation doivent intervenir
dans les prochains jours pour mettre à
la disposition des trois communes
principalement concernés c'est-à-dire la
tranche la faute et l'aiguillon des
dispositions qui leur permettront de
réfléchir sur les thèmes que je vais
évoquer qui sont ceux que vous
connaissez bien
avec bien évidemment la dimension qui
concerne les documents d'urbanisme en
termes d'assistance je pense que la
responsabilité doit être celle des élus
locaux
et avec le contrôle régalien de l'état
qui a la responsabilité notamment
fonctions régaliennes intégrité du
territoire aussi intégrité du territoire
qui ne se défend pas seulement avec des
mirage ou avec des grands bateaux mais
également aussi avec des mesures de
protection du trait de côte par exemple
mais donc mesures d'assistance en la
matière y compris qu'ils peuvent aller
dans ce domaine là d'autres d'autres
éléments très concrets sur les
dimensions qui sont liés à aux activités
aux activités économiques de ces
territoires
bon on connaissait ces lieux là c'est
quand même une vocation touristique
pense qu'ils doivent la conserver a
conservé en matière portuaire aussi bien
pour la pêche pour l'ostréiculture la
mytiliculture que pour la voile
également il y a des perspectives et je
pense qu'on a des marges de progrès sur
ces territoires pour peu que tout le
monde le veuille bien compris l'état par
rapport au domaine au domaine maritime
et donc nous sommes dans cette dans
cette logique là pour pouvoir faire en
sorte j'oubliais le logement parce qu'on
s'aperçoit qu'il ya quand même des
politiques du logement qui sont
complètement déficientes en la matière
et notamment en matière de logements
locatifs dans ce dans ce secteur-là a
non seulement pour permettre aux
personnes de pouvoir se reloger mais
également d'avoir une démarche
d'aménagement du territoire et de
logement qui soit conforme à ce qu'on
est en droit d'attendre aujourd'hui se
pose la question de l'intercommunalité
dans ce secteur-là qui doit permettre
également comme dans d'autres mers
notamment qui doit permettre d'avoir des
projets des projets collectifs
c'est aussi pour nous compte tenu des
compétences qui sont celles de la région
les logiques lié à la formation aux
infrastructures aux infrastructures
notamment dimension des acteurs
concernés par cette par cette démarche
là je pense que tout ça est en place et
devrait permettre si les acteurs le
souhaitent et en liaison avec les
recommandations qui peuvent intervenir
de facilité si les acteurs locaux le
souhaitent
la réflexion pour pour préparer pour
préparer l'avenir
je termine sur sur les digues
plus généralement donc les mesures
d'urgence j'en évoqué sg dit sur
l'avenir
je crois qu'il ya eu une mission qui est
venu sur les dégâts n'a pas daigné
interroger les collectivités locales
notamment les régions bon bref c'est en
des termes peu habitués à cette démarche
là on n'a pas été bon mais les régions
sont absentes des missions d'état est ce
que je voudrais vous dire c'est que bien
évidemment il ya là une situation très
très complexe qui remonte au moyen-âge
pour certaines sur certains aspects et
qui mérite effectivement une vraie
stratégie l'actualité des régions et des
débats que l'on connaît mme hamel à dire
que compte tenu de l'absence actuelle
compte tenu de la loi de finances du
mois de décembre 2009 les régions ne
sont pas en mesure de financer quoi que
ce soit dans ce domaine là puisque vous
le savez nous ne disposons plus les
régions françaises ne disposeront plus
ne dispose plus de levier fiscal
d'aucun levier fiscal et que par
conséquent il nous est impossible
aujourd'hui ce pas une mesure
caractériel c'est valable dans tous les
domaines de s'engager de quelques
manières que ce soit pour financer des
actions ou des opérations qui ne sont
pas de notre compétence
nous n'avons aujourd'hui aucune marge de
manoeuvre fiscale et indépendamment du
contexte de crise où la difficulté que
l'on connaît actuellement cette mesure
date et y compris sur la base sur ce
qu'était celle de la région jusqu'à
présent c'est-à-dire et les 15% me
semble-t-il je dis qu'actuellement je ne
suis pas en mesure nous ne sommes pas en
mesure de prendre aucun engagement je
dis pas qu'il peut y avoir des céréales
c'est pas une mesure de blocage ni
caractériel nous sommes en situation de
ne pas avoir aujourd'hui aucune
lisibilité
on essaie il ya des certitudes ce qu'il
ya plus de marques fiscale la plus de
marche fiscale
et par conséquent si l'on veut respecter
et honorer les engagements qui sont ceux
que l'on a pris sur les compétences qui
sont les nôtres vis-à-vis compris du
personnel a quand même quelques salariés
supplémentaires depuis la loi du 13 août
je suis incapable incapables nous sommes
incapables de pouvoir honorer y compris
des engagements qu'on a pu prendre dans
certains domaines c'est une position
encore une fois de l'ensemble des
régions françaises sur dans tous les
domaines je voulais vous faire préciser
c'est un c'est une position qu'on peut
reprendre comme une position de la rfm 8
parce que les igg intello jorrin région
d'après non mais on a on a des milliers
de kilomètres de digues aussi bien
fluvial hier que maritime
donc ça concerne à mon avis pas de tout
repos pas loin toutes les régions
françaises
cette position là est une position de
les rêves qu'on peut tous qu'on pourrait
traduire par le fait que dans le
prochain près plan digues les régions
n'apporteraient pas leurs échos je peux
vous dire que les rares et peu ma
réponse au titre des régions est celle
que je viens d'exprimer que je reformule
en réponse à votre interrogation dans
l'état actuel des choses c'est à dire
avec une absence de marges de manoeuvre
fiscales de lisibilité sur les
ressources des régions n'est ce pas nous
sommes incapables de prendre des
engagements supplémentaires par rapport
à ce que nous avons pris notamment majid
pro personnellement considéré qu'un
certain nombre d'engagements vis-à-vis
du contrat de projet je n'étais pas en
mesure probablement de les respecter
monsieur malvy a déclaré ya quelques
jours par rapport les engagements pour
achat train par rapport à la sncf que
notions et non pas capable
éventuellement d'honorer ses engagements
donc nous sommes dans une période
d'attenté par rapport à cela qu'ils
nécessitent n'avons pas connaissance de
façon extrêmement précise des conditions
des ressources que nous disposons
disposeront en 2011 par nous connaissons
la disparition de la taxe
professionnelle et il n'y a plus qu
aucune marge de manoeuvre si ce n'est la
taxe sur les cartes grises monsieur le
sénateur dont
là l'an dernier les immatriculations ont
baissé dans la région des pays de la
loire de près de 16% ce pas je veux dire
que c'est une réalité très très très
forte ce partant de la tpp autres là
dessus donc ça c'est un constat loi de
finances s'applique pour l'année 2010 et
les années qui viennent
je pense qu'elle n'est pas sans
conséquence réelle sur les moyens dont
disposent des régions et donc ma réponse
est très très clairs au nom de la greffe
après moi je vous avais terminé le point
restant sur plan d'aidé puisque nous y
étions on va se déporter de la question
strictement financière la région est
intervenu régulièrement et ça c'est un
certain point historique
donc vous avez un certain nombre de
pratiques d'expérience qu'est ce qu'il
faut que le plan digues n'oublie pas
qu'est ce qu'est ce que c'est que pour
vous en au delà de on attend
l'engagement de l'état serait soutenue
robuste en était en l'an de l'autre jour
et on a vu que ils ont un mécanisme d'
agences de l'eau différent des autres
mais ils ont de leur à jour du lot une
contribution sur l'eau potable sur le
traitement et en même temps sur la
protection mais mais c'est quand même
important puisque eux calcul qu'avec le
changement climatique
à chaque fois que on augmente de 25 cm
le niveau de la mer il augmentait chez
eux son genre en climatique de 40
centimètres en deux siècles depuis dix
huit ans donc ils compris les 10 bornes
en en a' en vendée alors pays de la
loire des dix qui ont été réalisés en
1800 mm
et même avant d'envoyer un petit peu la
corrélation entre la cote de la digue et
puis la cote du niveau de la mer il nous
dit que à chaque fois qu'on augmente de
50% de 50 cm un événement auquel est une
occurrence d'un siècle revenaient tous
les dix ans qui était dans donc on a
quand même besoin d'un plan dis donc
qu'est ce qu'il faudrait que le plan
digues n'oublie pas pour que ce soit un
bon plan dit il selon vous est ce que
vous êtes favorable défavorable aux orcs
et ossements épars le mathy qui se pose
est elle-même de la gouvernance est ce
qu'il faut un gros machin nationale ou
est-ce qu'il faut plutôt une gestion
locale est ce qu'il faut
comment dirais-je est pas la clé si la
question des propriétés ça nous concerne
moi même on a quand même un peu de
propriété privée etc
qu'est ce qui pour vous c'est quoi un
bon plan digues voilà bah on l'a évoqué
un peu à travers les principes j'aurais
sur les principes
c'est le sens de votre question les
principes c'est effectivement l'état
responsabilité régalienne de l'état donc
les règles doit être fixée nationalement
et pouvoir être décliné alors là je
partage ce que suggérait votre
questionnement
c'est pas de paris qu'on peut régler
l'ensemble des dossiers territoriaux et
donc l'implication des acteurs du du
territoire est tout à fait nécessaire
la dimension de la propriété au delà de
la propriété de la responsabilité doit
être clairement est beaucoup mieux
identifier et je citais tout à l'heure
le secteur de bois hêtre beauvoir est
évident que des situations comme
celles-ci sont pas tenables n'est ce pas
laisser jeu reprend les propos du maire
que vous connaissez bien également
disant qu' il m'arrive de me lever la
nuit pour faire le tour
faire le tour sur ces 21 km de digues
pour voir s'il n'y a pas une catastrophe
pour la matière donc cette réalité là ça
n'empêchera pas le sens des
responsabilités des élus locaux mais je
pense que ça doit être effectivement le
l'occasion de pouvoir clarifier à la
fois le terme de propriété mais je pense
que c'est pas l'élément essentiel mais
en tout cas de qui est responsable de
quoi en la matière les territoires
doivent être bien évidemment concerné
jeudi territoire les ressources sont
bien évidemment on a dit un mot tout à
fait essentiel au delà du constat de
propriété de et de responsabilité mais
la dimension territoriale c'est le sens
que vous aviez noter je crois dans la
première conclusion de vos auditions
je pense qu'il faut absolument qu'il y
ait une implication une responsabilité
des territoires quand j'ai du territoire
ça concerne évidemment les différents
niveaux d'institutions d'institutions
territoriale avec des financements qui
sont aptes qui se sont appropriés qui
s'inscrivent dans la durée et qui se
sont pas soumis aux aléas que l'on vient
d'évoquer tout à l'heure ainsi quand
même bien fait sur lesquels j'ai oublié
de vous questionner mais vous serez que
je veux un peu concerné même très
concerné quand même c'est que l'état
imagine dans son plan de financement sur
les digues de mobiliser un certain
nombre de ressources peut importer dans
ses ressources ya l'idée d'un
redéploiement
on a rencontré n'était à bruxelles on a
rencontré d'ailleurs le commissaire
européen qu'un chargé politique
régionale un redéploiement du feder
est-ce que vous en avez alors parce
qu'il ya une cogestion du feder mme
semble-t-il au niveau territorial
régional envers l'état régional
et et conseiller régional d'accord est
ce que c'est une information qu'on vous
a donné que vous avez eue et si oui est
ce que vous y travailler de concert avec
avec l'état fait prévoit une information
là-dessus récente ya trois données dans
la relation avec la première c'est celle
d'ailleurs que votre vos premiers
travaux ont signalé la région d'ailleurs
avait délibéré sur la question également
c'est la gestion du fonds de solidarité
de lavelanet fait suffisamment donc vous
savez c'est en plus étant en cours
d'examen et commission européenne je
crois que l'état n'a pas complètement
encore rendu son rapport
interministériel qui était attendu par
l'europe
on a quand même bon espoir que le ffs
yeux interviennent pour couvrir une part
des dépenses publiques qui ont été
assumés par les pouvoirs publics au sens
large du terme
moi je suis simplement une observation
plus tôt un objectif et il me paraît
essentiel que la gestion des effets sur
eux que l'autorité de gestion puisque ce
ne sont pas les régions en france vous
le savez dommage que cette gestion par
l'autorité de gestion soit assurée par
les deux préfets de région je sais que
des opérations ou manoeuvres sont en
cours pour que ce soit plus l'un que
l'autre
n'oublions pas que poitou charentes a
été très touchée mais pays la loire l'a
été également y compris sur deux
départements donc il faudrait pas
oublier que la remontée de la tempête et
les faits dont vous parliez sur la
gestion des digues aussi concerné duster
de la loire s'est pas fait sur les faits
sur ce et c'est un dossier difficile je
veux sans s'en est rendu compte alors
bon peut-être que la commission
pour aider la france malgré tout est
exceptionnellement pourrait faire un
geste mais c'est un dossier qui est
compliqué et si vous avez l
interlocuteur qui selon l'inspecteur
général c'est michel castet actif vous
auriez utilement peut-être un contact
avec lui tout à fait dans notre servent
à sion valais plus pour l'état pour la
gestion de la presse ici à bruxelles
décidé le fsu a pour une autre tempête
le deuxième cran dans la gestion des
relations avec l'europe c'est celui que
vous soulignez sur les tenants des
cofinancements feder pour les digues
alors moi je crois que c'est important
qu'on me dise du feder pour ludique
parce que il faut une mobilisation de
tous et l'europe est bien placé ceci dit
moi je il faudra aussi qu'on nous
rappelle les cohérences de
d'intervention de l'état président de
république a annoncé 50 % de financement
d'état sur les plans d'urgence sur les
digues puis 40%
il faudrait pas que le financement
européen viennent en déduction du
financement national par une banda
compris moi aussi d'ailleurs je l'avais
dit à monsieur borloo c'est 46 voilà
bloqué 1.10 ce point d'être important -
pour la gestion d'urgence
il faut que les engagements de chacun
soient tenus et que le financement
européen permettent de faire plus mais
permettent pas un des financeurs de
faire moins troisième observation sur la
gestion du feder et on nous rentrons
récemment dans la discute sur l'art vise
à mi-parcours de la gestion des paies au
feder c'est une entrave au monde est en
cours de faire et que avec bruxelles je
pense qu'on serait inspiré état région
europe et territoires à réfléchir comme
le président de région l'a dit réfléchir
à l'après crise dire qu'on aura à
mobiliser des financements publics pour
préparer l'après tempête parce que ces
territoires vont être impactés
lourdement et je pense que s'il serait
pas inutile de réfléchir sur les deux
régions à des financements dédiés feder
pour financer des investissements
publics structurants qui permettront à
cet événement de s'en sortir
là on est tout à fait d'accord pour
pouvoir réutiliser aurait orientés dans
le graphe de rajustement du contrat de
projet à grains orientés et dû l'aider
mais vous n'avez pas été saisi en tant
qu'institution cogestionnaire du feder
d'éventuellement
déploiement avant 2013 non d'accord et
on doit cette les préfère à ma
connaissance n'ont pas reçu leur lettre
de mission de révision à mi parcours on
est dans ce calendrier la non mais la
feuille de route doit arriver au mois de
mai au mois de juillet pour pouvoir être
traités à l'automne ça me permet de
lancer également une interrogation on
revit à mi parcours les p o feder au
même moment on revisite mi parcours le
cpe air avec la question pourrait se
poser que l'état dise bah oui je n'ai
pas eu la délivrance de mobiliser comme
on l'avait fait par le passé d'aidé des
crédits sur sur les digues
mais dans ce cas là la région si c'est
ce que ça serait si l'état venait sur ce
sujet il faudrait que ce soit avec des
abondements de crédits de l'état vous
aide à la gestion à mi-parcours d'un cpe
rc on utilise les crédits du cpr pour
les redistribuer
c'est à dire que si l'état veut venir
sur ce sujet il faut qu'il vienne et de
là c'est aussi cet été leurs
négociations avec l'état de d'accord 7
et point important quand même et c'est
là que ce que reprend sur la dimension
d'un contrat territorial spécifique
compris avec département les
départements régions est haute pour
préparer l'avenir sur les différents
thèmes peut être inscrit comme étant un
contrat spécifique d'après trempette
comme il y en a eu un
en 99 l'état des faits banals absolument
à garges en plus je me souviens
parfaitement très bien pour alors bien
sûr pour vous n'avez pas la compétence
de l'urbanisme je pense que
globalis vote est géré dans la proximité
donc vous n'avez pas la voir non plus
bon heur moins bon la région vous avez
quand même une compétence aménagement du
territoire et sur la grand serbe en tant
qu'ong l'os de compétence générale
sénateurs je suis déjà peut déjà voir au
sénat ce que j'avais dit sur l'article
bon je me prépare pour quelques jours
sur ce que les députés ont fait
mais au delà la clause générale de
compétence
donc on peut pas on peut difficilement
séparer donc la gestion du risque de
l'aménagement du territoire tout à fait
tout à fait je pense je les ai évoqué
tout à leur vue bien ça ces jeunes et
très bien et je et d'environnement cela
et d'environnement
quelle est votre approche justement de
comment dirais-je
on a construit quand même en dépit du
bon sens je crois qu'il ya une pression
dire que on a au plein planétaire une
pression sur tous les littoraux eau dans
le monde entier bon on a en plus un
changement climatique
donc on a un problème avec des risques
qui risque qui peuvent redevenir façon
plus récurrente on a une population qui
s'agrège comment vous voyez ces choses
là en terme d'aménagement du territoire
sur le littoral est-ce que et sur
l'urbanisme
est-ce que je suis parfaitement d'accord
l'état régalien bon maintenant est ce qu
il a toujours eu le bon contrôle de
légalité c'est un fait avéré extrêmement
lacunaires
bon comment vous une institution
régionale quel regard vous posez sur sur
ce point-là d'aménagement du territoire
d'urbanisme de construction parfois un
peu désordonné en tout cas une très
forte pression locale c'est difficile
pour des élus locaux d'y résister
lorsque il s'inscrit dans le
développement aussi leur commune de leur
collectivité
quel est votre regard sur moi je crois
que beaucoup de choses ont été
dit à cette occasion mais c'est pas
uniquement à cette occasion je pense que
la pression dont vous faites état est
une réalité et par conséquent il faut
qu'il y ait des règles
ça va de soi il faut surtout qu'on
contrôle les conditions dans lesquelles
ces règles sont respectées ou pas je
pense aussi et je crois que votre regard
sur ce qui se passe à l'étranger
démontre que il y a aussi des
adaptations des modes même d'aménagement
et de construction qu'ils peuvent
trouver un certain nombre de réponses
ah non pas des risques maximum crois
qu'il ya des endroits où bien évidemment
l'interdiction de construire doit être
claire et nette est respecté mais il y a
aussi d'abord je pense pas que dans
votre rapport vous allez proposer de
démolir toutes les maisons non pas dans
les zones noires tels que ceux ci a été
arrêté et modifié on peut dire là dessus
que les conditions dans lesquelles tout
ça a été présenté est pour le moins
discutable n'est ce pas et qu'on a créé
de l' angoisse de l'anxiété et du
désespoir inutilement n'est ce pas après
ces événements dramatiques et donc je
crois que pour être allé dans dans
certaines maisons quand il ya un étage
quelques à des constructions le long de
la loire puisqu'il n'y a pas que la cote
n'est ce pas qui est vulnérable aux
risques et et aux inondations et bien
d'autres bien d'autres lieux
je crois qu'il ya aussi des mesures je
dirais technique n'est ce pas qui
permette non pas d'éliminer les risques
mais de prendre un certain nombre de
mesures qui sont celles qui ont été
évoquées et qui ont permis un certain
nombre de familles
de vivre cet événement exceptionnel
insiste sur le caractère exceptionnel
sans savoir de drames personnels
donc je crois que il me semble qu'il ne
faut pas tomber je souffrais jusque là
dans une logique qu'ils soient liés
uniquement à l'événement et qui
interdisent de développement des
communes je crois qu'il faut avoir hélas
la marge est étroite
n'est ce pas pour les pouvoirs publics
et pour la réglementation mais les
mesures on l'a vu les mesures à la serpe
simpliste qui consiste à dire voilà il
ya des zones c'est fini c'est terminé
en la matière alors qu'il ya des gens
moi j'en ai rencontré qui bien
évidemment ne souhaite pas revenir sur
ce territoire là d'autres qui étaient
dans le noir et qu'il n'avait pas eu un
millimètre d'eau dans l'eure dans l'eure
dans leur propriété d'autres qui ont
vécu ça comme un élément effectivement
exceptionnelle mais qui ne mettait pas
en péril la vie des personnes qui
habitaient dans cette dans cet espace là
je crois que là-dessus on a réagi
beaucoup beaucoup trop vite en la
matière je pense qu'il faut
effectivement que un certain nombre de
mesures mais c'est pas uniquement sur
cette partie du jury du littoral on a
connu dans d'autres régions du littoral
des éléments de spéculation foncière de
spéculation immobilière qui ont pas
entraîner des conséquences comme ce
haut-lieu humaines au même titre que
celle que l'on a connue sur le sur le
sud et sur les deux régions
mais qui a entretenu une dégradation en
matière d'environnement globalement
n'est ce pas donc moi je crois qu'il
faut considérer que le développement que
l'on qualifie durable aujourd'hui doit
être un axe qui bien évidemment prennent
pas en compte la sécurité des personnes
mais crée les conditions et garantissent
aussi des conditions pour les communes
concernées qui sont aussi capables d'un
certain nombre d'adaptations et
d'ajustement de pouvoir continuer à
avoir des perspectives alors la marge
est étroit du rhin le compath façon
précise à cet cette démarche la wii par
les joies me montre ce que j'avais sur
mon papier également c'est le problème
du foncier ou connaissez ce foncier qui
a quelques comptes
quelques difficultés dans l'ensemble des
régions pour pouvoir disposer de
d'outils qui permettent justement une
régulation sur le
sur le sur le foncier établissement
public foncier soit départementale soit
régionale n'est ce pas qui est aussi un
outil public pour créer des conditions à
la fois d'un usage qui va se poser pour
les terrains les territoires qui ne
peuvent plus être constructibles mais je
crois que c'est évident et puis
également pour permettre également ce
développement dont deux que je cite
également je pense pour être là encore
au delà de la construction
si dans les estuaires on y développe pas
des activités maritimes aussi bien en
termes de culture marine que de voile
que d'autres d'autres activités où on va
le faire donc il faut aussi qu'il y ait
dans ce domaine là au delà de l'émotion
de la réflexion en termes de prévention
qui est tout à fait nécessaire
il faut aussi que l'on considère que les
activités humaines doit pouvoir
continuer à s'y exercer avec le maximum
de précautions mais ça doit être aussi
un élément qui rééquilibre les discours
un peu hâtif que l'on a pu entendre au
cours de ces derniers mois
hier en gironde le préfet de région
dominique schmitt qui était ainsi dgcl
nous indiquer quelle était la stratégie
de l'état sur l'estuaire de la gironde
et ne faisait part de sa volonté de
créer un établissement public foncier
d'état sur sur son département sur sa
région j'imagine d'ailleurs aussi pour
terminer peut-être laissé ce sera
peut-être le temps la conclusion donc on
essaie en même temps de voir ce que
chaque niveau de collectivité donc allée
commune bien sûr qu'ils aient vraiment
les selon proches les départements avec
l'incompétence et puis et puis les
régions on essaie de voir ce que chaque
niveau institutionnel de collectivité
peut apporter dans cette espèce
d'articulation qu'en france on n'a pour
l'instant pas réussi de gestion du
risque et de gestion de l'espace c'est à
dire la gestion du risque
l'environnement voilà on a connu des
digues qui ne se faisaient pas parce
qu'il y avait une opposition entre les
environnementalistes
acteurs ou au tout les développeurs bon
mais qu'est ce que la région peut
apporter en matière de politique d'une
plus grande culture du risque en france
qu'est ce que la région peut apporter
justement dans cette articulation où il
faut à la fois mieux gérer le risque
pour pouvoir prévenir on n'éliminera pas
mais en même temps continuer à
développement dans moi ne pas
démissionner pour laisser le trait de
côte manger par la mer bon on entendu
ici un sur deux
ce discours qui sont des discours pas de
problème un peu près le développement la
mer ça va ça vient et on laisse faire
qu'est ce que le niveau régional excusez
moi c'est au-delà même de la région pour
me payer la loire
qu'est ce que le niveau régional peut
apporter demain comme contribution sur
cette culture du risque et cette
articulation avec leur image en espace
je crois que ça se situe d'abord dans
des réflexions qu'on a qu'on a développé
déjà ou des documents existent déjà mais
qu'ils ne prenaient pas en compte de
façon systématique cet aspect des choses
c'est schéma régional d'aménagement et
développement durable du territoire
je pense que si l'on considère que les
régions notamment ou encore une
responsabilité par rapport à
l'aménagement du territoire au sens
large il y a donc nécessité d'avoir un
document prescriptif qu'il n'est pas
aujourd'hui qu'il n'est pas aujourd'hui
c'est c'est le vrai débat des régions
entre autres si on les fameux schéma
qu'on est tous en train d'élaborer pour
savoir si c'est des documents pour se
faire plaisir ou pour faire de la
communication ou si ce sont des
documents qui sont des documents
prescriptif et donc je crois que dans
une logique qui est celle que
questionnement vous est posée que vous
posez je pense que les régions si on
considère qu'elles ont encore un avenir
dans ce domaine là doivent être porteurs
en liaison avec l'ensemble des acteurs
c'est pas une logique entre une voie de
d'exclusivité en la matière mais de la
réalisation d'un schéma régional
d'aménagement et développement du terril
de développement du dire des durable du
territoire
ça doit bien évidemment intégré plus
qu'on ne l'a fait
jusqu'à maintenant la dimension et dans
un territoire comme le nôtre où dans
tous les territoires
cette dimension de prévention des
risques qui fait partie des éléments qui
concilie à la fois la nécessité sur
laquelle on vient de de débattre mais
également l'avenir en termes de
développement développement économique
développement et c'est donc moi je pense
que le rôle des régions c'est de pouvoir
être fédérateur et porteur d'un tel d'un
tel document qui devient précipite actif
avec toute la démarche de partenariat en
la matière c'est ce qu'on a fait mais
pas dans une logique à la fois de
prescriptive y compris intégrant un
volet risque qui dans les documents
qu'on a traité est insuffisamment
traitée et ça me permet de rebondir s
quel est votre sentiment sur nous le
sentiment que la mission a c'est que la
politique du littoral qui devrait être
une grande cause nationale parce que on
est on est pas l'autriche on est la
france qu'on a un littoral à loger plus
grand respect pour l'autriche mature
mais on n'est pas un été à contient
central je veux dire des avalanches
aussi là oui c'est vrai c'est vrai mais
on a quand même le sentiment un peu d'un
abandon de ce point de vue là et quand
on regarde à côté et y compris
d'ailleurs dans les assemblées on
constate que les montagnards sont très
organisés que systématiquement il ya pas
une loi sectorielle qui passe sans qu'il
y ait un volet pratique par montagne bon
est ce qu'il faut est ce qu'il faut pas
réincarner ça au niveau national quand
même sur sur un certain nombre de
dimensions d'ailleurs qu'ils quittent
qui sont à libération dont on discute
depuis début de notre entretien de
transition aussi bien donc risque
environnement mais aussi développement
économique spécificité littoral parce qu
on traite les choses bout par bout petit
bout par petit bout en réaction toujours
par rapport à des événements des crises
on parle pas de politique de la pêche
mais bon il ya quand même des politiques
yahia sur le littoral je pense un
certain de problématiques qui se posent
et qui doivent rester aussi du du
ressort de l'état en tout cas l'état
peut pas s'en désintéresser
quel est votre
perception des choses vocabulaire qu'on
utilise dans une région qui à 450 km de
côtes
c'est sous le vocabulaire d'économie
maritime économie maritime au sens large
d'espoir qui intègre aussi bien le
tourisme qui représente quand même un
élément tout à fait essentiel
d'attractivité du territoire pas
seulement pour les français mais pour
les européens en général et puis toutes
les activités qui sont liées à la mer
aussi bien la partie nautique que la
partie qu'à la partie pêche ou
aquaculture donc je pense que qu'il y
ait une réflexion nationale sur une
politique de l'économie maritime au sens
large puisque c'est le vocabulaire que
que l'on eut scully je sais pas si c'est
le bon hein mais oui mais quand je dis
économique au sens économique du terme
durable éco système etc puisque c'est
c'est aussi comme ça qu'on essayait de
le traiter dans dans la région je pense
que cette cette démarche là l'état ne
peut pas s'en abstraire très bien
écouter merci merci de la réponse
précise à l'ensemble c'est est ce qu'il
ya un point non conclusion n'y a pas de
je crois qu'on a on a évoqué sur le
premier point
excusez moi ça paraît peut-être est un
peu en décalage par rapport à l'émotion
qu'a suscitée cette démarche là mais je
crois aussi qu'il ya une démarche un peu
d'humilité c'est pas forcément mon genre
par rapport aux rapports entre l'homme
et la nature n'est ce pas mais je crois
qu'il faut vraiment aussi avoir le en
toile de fond cette réalité là quoi
puisque vouloir y compris dans la loi et
dans les règles et éliminer tous les
risques
tous les risques naturels on sait bien
hélas dans ce domaine là que il ya quand
même une catastrophe exceptionnelle dans
une conjoncture exceptionnelle même si
les risques dans ce domaine là peuvent
être accrues donc je crois que les les
efforts y compris ça concerne
l'adaptation de l'immobilier ça concerne
les éléments d'information qu'on a
indiqué je crois que ce volet là
pas été au moment de l'émotion n'a pas
été traitée quoi me semble-t-il
écoutez c'est la raison pour laquelle
moi j'ai on a demandé à ce que l'on
additionne en soi et vale qui est un
sociologue un peu spécialiste du risque
qui dans huit jours viendra nous parler
voilà parce que je pense qu'il ya en
même temps il faut que l'action est
importante mais doit s'enraciner
oscillant dans cette réflexion de du
rapport de l'homme à la nature
j'ai président merci de cette audition
c'est la fin de cette audition si vous
souhaitez la revoir notre site internet
publicsenat.fr prochain rendez vous avec
les travaux parlementaires cet après
midi 15 heures avec la suite de l'examen
du projet de loi de réforme des chambres
de commerce et d'industrie
bonne journée à tous sur public sénat